how's it going resumes parapa and
welcome back
finally to some more Walking Dead
episode 2 season 2 and it's a little bit
confusing I've been getting so many
messages of people be like why don't you
play more but the game isn't released
yet and it's been crazy I'll take that
as you bros are just excited to see more
I'm excited to see play more with you so
without further ado let's begin baby
previously on The Walking Dead
I'm freezing wait till we get up the
Wellington then talk to me about cold
I'm gonna go look for more wood where's
the rest of your group I'm by myself
[ __ ] again I'm out
grabber let's go
someone mind telling me what the [ __ ]
going on here fine dog for all we know
she could be working with Harper so
since you're pretty much on your own
monster plan
well you're welcome to stay here if you
want a beginning somebody come and
saying I look like that guy
think about it your Carver what you do
who's Carver
with Krista
ah I'm fine I'm fine just just lost my
footing see you got men cut this way
damn and you get your asses over here
both of you
we have to go could have saved him
how can I just leave him uh see he did
get back so I mean we're gonna pick him
he's gonna die anyway I'm just saying I
made the right choice you don't know
what you're talking about
oh you wouldn't maybe the same that's
cool all right let's do this uh what is
happening now is this supposed to be
home Clemmy I can Bambi's be so strong
like there has to be like old bones and
chain uh what's the plan
oh thanks fine
oh that's pretty good plan boxes zandi's
biggest weakness well that was fun
are you crazy crazy
maybe aah
why'd you leave my uncle bed you ever
back in the stream why'd you follow me
Pete got bay Pete got bit what he got
bit he wasn't going to make it Toby I
know I thought it was his dad I don't
know is his uncle see it's not so bad
what do we do now
I don't care if we're stuck here we
should at least look around maybe we can
find something to help us get out of
here knock yourself out
all right well I guess we got to do all
the work while he sits um being a little
a little too she paints so the first
episode was supposed to be like um
welcome back to Walking Dead and desert
stuff let me see what is that stuff what
do you say is that Jam I love Jam that's
my jam okay that's not my jam
okay it's my job it's not my jam whiskey
that's my jam now what oh [ __ ] if I know
we wait I guess I think climb is too
young to drink
anyway was saying Episode two is like
when shits supposed to hit the fan at
least that that's what they told me and
that sounds pretty awesome sir oh [ __ ]
zombies turn
sounds like turned on old people I don't
know why hey stop
ah okay you're scaring me you're scaring
me
don't scare Clemmy stop it no don't you
do that mister that's right
I had to kill my mom
I am sounds weird when I said Luke
always used to push me I never wanted to
go into business with it
I remember when he sold me on his big
plan some [ __ ] plan case of beer and
he just said Nick we're burning daylight
that was that after six months we were
flat broke
man care we were having fun
I wish I was like him I wish I could
just keep moving all the time I'm just
not built like that
everyone I grew up with it all happened
to them
no it's gonna happen to us hey you don't
know that
we're also [ __ ] we'll make it he'll make
it
[ __ ] I mean what's the point
we'll just March some new place and
somebody else will die it's never gonna
stop eventually it'll be our turn I
can't believe we've been here a day a
day it's been a day right hmm hey kid
Oh No drink with me don't don't ask me
that I'm gonna be your first and your
last no thanks okay thanks listen
they're not coming for us
you should go run for it what are you
gonna do stay here I'm tired
go find Luke and the rest they'll take
care of you
yeah he reminds me of mustache man I
knew someone I can you
he was always screwing up - no I mean
Ben I didn't ask for any of this
nobody does that's so what should we use
reverse psychology or not okay comedy
are you kidding leave all this you can't
just sit here and die why not
what does it matter you still have Luke
and everyone else they're family
Nick I need your help please
come on you're right oh really
I mean of course yeah now look if we get
separated cabins only half a mile from
here you can't miss it
hey you ready no not at all this has got
to be so bad yeah come on what don't
don't yell on me man yeah I think so she
suck you a mess ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh good job
that's great
how about you run here we go come on you
know get the [ __ ] out of here
gofer neck I said get the [ __ ] out what
when we save him come on
yeah he's not evil he's like
there's no way
you watch I feel like I made the wrong
decisions again well it seemed like he
will say that anyway I don't know if
raking out it wasn't even that far why
did you just sign I don't notice a oh
well Clementine are you alright Luke's
not with you can be awkward
where's Alvin what happened
you spent hours where are they Clem Pete
you got Ben what what happened walkers
what do you think avens where were you
where were you exactly down by the
stream we gotta go
just hold on a minute my husband is
still out there
get the guns
Lucan Alvin went out looking for you I
told him not to go
oh damn it Luke Clementine
can can you please watch Sarah she's
upstairs just distract her and don't
tell her nothing okay trust me you can
trust me
sorry I don't care where you'll be safe
I be back soon
and thank you okay
you can test me it's like a problem a
doubt so if you remember his daughter
it's like he's trying to like create a
fake where I land nothing but huh I
found this under the house there was all
kinds of old stuff it's so cool
take one of me come on take one of me
you should see everybody yeah okay sure
sorry let's play our freaking
babysitting part out okay sorry there's
no good poison you I hate to break it to
you oh god you're right I'm just game
what's wrong um where's my dad it's
beautiful don't worry about uh they're
uh very me yeah they're fishing fishing
I know that's not true
yeah come on hey
she knows huh sorry I just need to hey
looks back is that the guy that looks
like me yeah I look like rice so has to
be they see gun fishing say that that
Tully fishing yeah um well nice Doc's
Mane's and thanks you guys what's going
on here oh it's not an oak it's not look
at all is it Oh sneaky sneaky climb no
one will know she's coming why she's so
slow come on come on go you can walk
that's right why do you look glum I
think I know him who is it he can't see
me you have to make a go away well let
me find go hide where oh I can't I can't
breathe
hello Kay hi Santa Claus oh hello hello
how are you
let's be okay how are you well I'm doing
just fine thank you
my family and I are set up a ways down
river on kind of surprised we haven't
run into each other yet what's your name
what's your name my name is George any
ignore e pleasure to meet you he seems
like big-time a bit and no not really
yes I do mind you mind
that's a nice outside place is there
anyone else around you know usually see
cabins this big out here I don't have
Hanson I could pack a lot of folks in
there
you can talk to me alright I'm not gonna
bite you
well I'll cut to the chase I'm out
looking for my people seven of them to
be exact
they've been gone a long while and I'm
worried they might have gotten lost
maybe you've seen him
Oh our boys in an old man Spanish guy
and his daughter Clara
they've taller than you big black guy
this big and pretty little pregnant lady
ah triple lot yes ray anything so he's
the guy uh-huh so they're running from
him why I don't this is one guy
why is she letting him super out come on
Clemmy a lot of plates for one person
looks like a tornado man through here
I don't like a lot of food okay well
believe me I don't either
just passing through her you've been
here a while hey listen kid I hope
you're not one of those nuts headed up
north looking for shangri-la now I'm not
sure why you'd go anywhere after finding
this place
well I just got here and I already don't
want to leave where do you live
yeah down by ever there there's a sweet
little spot with a boat where we pitched
camp got a few tents up and everything
else like I said I'm surprised we
haven't run into each other do you have
a dog no I don't he's what difference
does it make just wondering hmm that's
kind of awkward why does she want the
knife oh good job Club good job
ten points where does this go in your
butt sorry I mean over there uh in the
drawer there he's not gonna hurt us now
he's the type of guy that's polite but
when [ __ ] hits the fan it'll be a [ __ ]
that's something so you shouldn't do
anything I'm just saying it's a real
nice place kind of cozy
I knew a guy that always wore shirts
like this oh not sure yet of a [ __ ] but
a smart man and this uh what was his
name Carlos oh [ __ ] well well whites in
trouble three moves away from checkmate
uh uh I farted
sorry I come on it's like a cat ghosts
Philly annoying hey nobody's here
oh no okay this should I do press I
don't know what to do why would the help
us get out of my house [ __ ] she looks
dead so awkward I told you nobody's here
seems that way
didn't me sassy Clem it's good let's
just leave you here with a good
conscience if someone was poking around
right
sure oh no oh no oh no oh no uh-uh
who's this
now one exit says it's said says take
photo never seen her before
yeah ah sheriff I died who these people
are do you I don't know what you're
talking about
let me ask you this when you met him how
much did they trust you I'll let my
checks they what's your super point
people don't trust you how can you trust
them that's an accident good point
huh well I think I've troubled you long
enough I can let myself out
man he's really interesting why should
why should I just you have a real good
day now
Oh No why did I click that ah well he
knew anyway okay don't don't try to next
where is he he's gone what if he comes
back he's probably will gotta have to
end this episode here hope you bros
enjoy watching if you everyone now would
be a great time to leave a like I gotta
keep this a daily series so I'll see you
tomorrow with your episode until then
stay awesome rest